how are you i'm so good how are you
cheryl
that's so good to see you again so good
to see you too
my dogs are gonna walk right in the shot
there we go okay
and there it is all right
you are a new dog mom right i am a new
dog mom yes i have a little
a little pup named sam and he's the best
i just love having him around what's
your what's your pups name who does that
so that was murphy
and then there's buddy who's like a
smaller
smaller dog but yeah no we're dog crazed
over here
you you adopted sam is he gonna be
coming on tour
i'm hoping that's the plan yes we'll get
to that part where
once we get rolling in the bus um i
think he'll be able to come and join us
i'm looking amazing are you dog crazed
right now like are you like a full-on
dog mom
i understand it yes i feel like i
always loved getting to hang around
other people's dogs and was like oh this
is so sweet and wonderful and then now
that i have sam i'm like oh no i get it
on another level
like i understand what people mean it's
just this
little buddy who's just an unconditional
love it's the best
all right let's get to you and your
music
what was your reaction when you heard
that brothers osborne wanted you to open
for them
i was so excited seriously just
completely freaking out i've been the
biggest fan of their music for
so long i love all their records i love
the art that they make and what they
stand for
in their songs i just think they're such
important voices
in the country music community and and
i'm even more so a fan of just who they
are at human beings we've got to cross
paths at a lots of different
events here around nashville and they've
always just been so kind and welcoming
to me and
um to get to watch their show every
night on this tour is going to be such a
blast my band and are
so excited to watch and learn from them
and just so thrilled to get to play
again
we've our hearts i think everybody's
hearts has just been
a longing for that feeling of that
sacred community coming together again
so
um i can't i can't wait to get out there
we're so excited
uh have you got a chance to get to know
the guys what are they like
they are such sweet human beings like
and they love music so much it's my
favorite to get to like
watch them talk about you know their
their heroes and get to like see them on
stage literally having the time of their
life like they just
they love music they have so much fun
with it and um they're just hilarious
and
so sweet such cool human beings love
that
so you have had so much success um
with your debut album you took home
country album of the year at the juneau
awards
how would you describe your life right
now i mean
it's also surreal cheryl it's crazy i
keep
i keep my journal and i've i've just
been like processing
everything that's kind of been happening
happening in the last little while and
um it's been such a strange year to kind
of be celebrating things you know
celebrating feels feels different in
in the climate of the world and
everything we've all been going through
but
i think that has really shown me even
more so just to
to hold on to the special moments and to
be you know to feel even more so
grateful for them so
um all of those fun victories in in the
last little while have just been
so crazy and weird it's like weird to
hear you say it all out and wonderful
and the thing that i've been dreaming
about doing since i was a little kid is
happening right before my eyes and it's
so beautiful it's so much more beautiful
than i
i had pictured so um i'm so grateful to
get to do the thing that i love
oh that's amazing and and the new single
uh girl who didn't care set a record as
the number one
most added song at country radio
do those kind of accolades still blow
your mind
yes i mean an incredible thing to get to
celebrate the fact that
everybody at home you know with country
radio has just wrapped their arms around
this
entire adventure has just meant so much
to me it's
it's it i think it's even more special
just the fact that it is home
and to feel that community that i grew
up surrounded by really believing in
the music now is it's crazy and
so awesome and um that was really
exciting to get to be like okay
i've been working on so many new songs
this past year like writing music has
kept me sane
in this past this past little while of
being home so much and so i've just been
like
dying to get to start sharing this this
chapter of new music and to
introduce this this new season with girl
who didn't care is
just feels exactly right to me and to
feel such a warm reception to it was
so cool ah i love that and i love the
message of finding yourself again i
think no matter what
age you are what stage you're at in life
there's always room to find yourself
again talk a little bit about that
journey for you
thank you for saying that i i think it's
so important too i've definitely been
on that journey for myself this past
little while and yeah
i've been walking around my neighborhood
this past year something just feels
really therapeutic
about yeah one foot in front of the
other listening to music
and just taking in the neighborhood and
i've been admiring like the sidewalk
chalk art from all these different
neighbor kids and hearing them laughing
in the backyard and
something about that just kind of
brought me to thinking about what
courage
looks like and what it means to just
have that fearless spirit that we all
start with before
anyone tells us that our dreams are
crazy or that things are hard or
impossible it's just like we just
believe
yeah i would not be here doing this
whole music journey if it wasn't for
like
my seven or eight-year-old self who was
just like oh i'm gonna do this one day
like i just completely believed it so
i i could use more of that courage and
confidence in my life now i've been on a
journey for more of that
and this song was a part of that process
for me
so you have this brand new music video
please tell us all about it
we are getting to premiere it today i'm
so excited to get to share this music
video and
um appreciate you guys supporting it and
this
this song was really special to me in
wanting to
capture that fearless spirit that exists
in all of us and get to show
what that looks like and how we can hold
on to it as we grow up and so
i'm so honored to get to feature three
incredible women
in this music video who are sort of
in fields that are maybe traditionally
more male dominated
and have kind of persevered through all
the different kinds of uphills that are
a part of chasing any dream
and are completely you know in their
element doing it so we have
um alyssa carson who is currently
stutter studying astrobiology in florida
and aspiring to be an astronaut to be
among them one of the first people to
land on mars someday
and so she is in the middle of that
process right now and we're so excited
to get to feature her in this video we
have um
shannon wells who is a firefighter
here in nashville tennessee and i mean
what a hero she just has the kindest
spirit it was so wonderful to get to
know her through
shooting this music video and just her
her heart for serving others
is just something to me and then we have
sarah fuller who is somebody i got to
meet earlier this year and
what an inspiring woman she is a soccer
player she's a goalkeeper
and she got invited to play on the
vanderbilt boys football team
she's the first women in history to ever
play
and score points in a power five um
college football game and so she is in
this music video too
and then we have the younger versions
that we casted of all of these
incredible women so it's it gives me
goosebumps to watch this video and to
just think about how powerful it is to
see
real people and real stories and the way
that it just has the power to make us
feel like we can do anything in the
world
when we see we have the opportunity to
watch somebody else doing it
it's like wow this is a possible thing
so i can't wait for
so many little girls out there to get to
watch this and to feel like
there's a community of people cheering
them on and believing in them too
yes that's what we need we need more of
that for sure
um are you working towards a full-length
project and what story do you want to
tell with your music
i am i'm working on whatever this whole
next chapter of music is gonna look like
and
um i'm so thrilled to get to be starting
it with this song and the plan is to
kind of take everybody on the adventure
with me so keep releasing songs as we go
to get to the next collection of music
but i would say that the
the sort of anchor and theme to me is
um the way that the light gets in
through the cracks that's been something
i've been
processing a lot through i have these
guitars that i like to paint and kind of
make a time capsule
yes to represent the music that i'm
working on and so
i've just started to like tattoo the
next guitar
and the very first symbol i wanted to
include was a sunrise
um it feels like a new horizon and
kind of looking at the way that the
light's coming in so i'm looking forward
to sharing a lot of
new music very soon i love that too
what are your parents and your family
and your friends who are your friends
from when you were little what do they
all think of
all of this that's a good question
they're all so
wonderful and excited and um they've
been so
supportive of this adventure from when i
was you know five or six years old
singing singing in grand prairie alberta
and you know i used to
sing the anthem at all the hockey games
and yeah the different local theater
things and they were all so supportive
then they were just like the most
encouraging group of cheerleaders so it
feels like
um that that kind of belief it's really
wild when you have somebody who says
i believe in you and like i'm cheering
you on regardless of what
of what you're doing um i just think
that's such a beautiful thing so i'm
really grateful for the support that's
what it's all about right
yeah for sure it's fun to get to feel
like i can
carry that spirit with me wherever i go
you